Speaker 1: Donald Trump is going bonkers because
the Supreme Court has said this is it. Your tax
returns are going to the House committee that is
investigating you. The Supreme Court has said that
is it. Newsweek reporting Donald Trump's tax
returns at the mercy of leakers. And indeed,
as I've told you before, if and when
Trump's taxes get to that House committee.
A lot of different people on that committee could
leak the taxes. I believe the taxes will leak.
I'm not advocating for a leak. I'm not encouraging
criminality. I'm merely giving you my prediction.
My prediction is that these documents are of
such interest. That they will leak once they're
in the hands of that House committee. And indeed,
Newsweek reports, the Supreme Court decision to
allow Donald Trump's tax returns to be handed over
to a House committee will not result in the former
president's financial records becoming public
unless there is a leak. In a ruling Tuesday,
Supreme Court justices rejected Trump's attempt
to block a lower court decision to grant the
Democratic controlled Ways and Means Committee
access to the IRS records. Now, interestingly,
with the House taking over control in
January, there is a sort of time is of
the essence element to this. But Trump is going
bonkers posting to his platform truth, social.
Speaker 3: Truth, essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. Why would anybody be surprised
that the Supreme Court has ruled against me? They
always do. It is unprecedented to be handing over
tax returns and it creates terrible precedent
for future presidents. Has Joe Biden paid taxes
on all the money he made illegally from Hunter
and beyond? The Supreme Court has lost its honor,
prestige and standing. By the way, a third of
the Supreme Court is people Trump picked and
has become nothing more than a political body.
With our capital C country paying the price.
They refuse to even look at the election hoax
of 2020. Shame on them. I would expect expect
that Trump's taxes will leak if the House Ways and
Means Committee gets them, particularly if it gets
them with such little time to investigate before
Republicans take over control of the House. That's
a prediction. Let me know what you think. Leave
a comment if you're watching on YouTube and make
sure you're subscribed at YouTube.com slash. This
is new. YouTube is revamping everything. Okay.
YouTube.com slash at symbol The David Pakman Show.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is counting on
you to sign up. It joined pacman dot com. If you'd
like to support the work that we do, of course we
produce the show every day free for everybody to
listen to or to watch. It is subsidized by about
1% of our audience that supports us through the
membership program at Join Packman MEDCOM. You can
sign up and use the coupon code. 24 starts now.